[Music]  ah  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  pretty  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  team  [Music]  hey townscaper if you're hearing this  that means you made it to the end  i want to thank you so much for viewing  please make sure that you like and  subscribe when you like and subscribe it  really helps the channel out a lot  please make sure you follow me on  instagram and twitter the links are down  below in the description  and again i want to thank you so much  for checking in and i'll see you next  time  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you